-Our next guest is a writer,
director, and producer
you know from his work
on "Trainwreck,"
"Knocked Up," and
"The 40-Year-Old Virgin,"
as well as "Girls"
and "Freaks and Geeks."
His new film,
"The King of Staten Island,"
is available on demand now
Here's my conversation wit
our friend Judd Apatow.
Judd, it's great to see you.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing well.
I've been home
for over three months.
And this is the result.
-It's lovely.
It's beautiful.
I mean, you're in bloom.
You're in full bloom.
-Do you know that I did
my own makeup today?
-No. Get out of here.
-This is -- you know what,
I always have these
makeup people.
I can do it myself, which is
basically Irish Spring.
I use Irish Spring.
-Yeah.
-And then this is it.
I don't even have beard oil in
-How do the women --
the three women
that you live with feel
about your look right now?
-They feel the same way yo
feel, that it looks great.
-Yeah.
-That I'm glad
that we found this.
-A lot of support.
A lot of support.
-No, they are so annoyed because
they think it's too big
and they're mad I won't trim it,
but I'm going kind of
for a Benjamin Harrison look
-Yes.
-And they're mad at me because
I keep saying,
"Well, then I'm going to
shave it all off."
And they're like, "No, we don'
want to see your face!"
You know, they want
a little beard,
but they hate my face.
And I try to remind them,
"It's your face."
-Right, right.
-Like my face looks
kind of like your face.
You can't hate it that much.
-No, of course not.
That's very fair.
Although, it's not really
their fault,
but it's a fair assessment
So, the movie's great.
And I want to talk, becaus
I feel like you always do
such an incredible job
with casting,
especially casting that people
wouldn't expect.
I mean, obviously Marisa Tomei
is so great in this movie.
Steve Buscemi.
You know, Pete is so much fu
to watch.
Bill Burr is fantastic.
-Yeah.
But maybe Action Bronson
steals the movie.
-People aren't really
talking yet enough about
that Action Bronson
has a key role in the movie.
You know, we needed a strang
neighborhood figure.
I don't want to give away what
happens in the sequence.
And Action Bronson was the onl
one who was hysterically funny
And also Machine --
Machine Gun Kelly is
in the movie as well
as a mean tattoo shop owner.
So, you know,
I love having cameos like,
RZA is in "Funny People."
-Yeah.
-And Ghostface Killah
is in "Walk Hard."
And Method Man
is in "Trainwreck."
So I'm just working throug
the whole Wu-Tang Clan.
-Yes.
-It's my tribute to
Staten Island over a career.
-That's very -- that's
very nice of you to do.
We had Pete on and he talked
about, you know,
writing a first draft
of this movie.
I imagine, like,
for somebody like him
who's playing the lead
in a film that is also,
you know, to some degree
pulled from his own life,
did he have anxiety
in the early days of shooting?
-You know, he got very nervous
right before
we started shooting.
So, you know, we were having fun
writing for a couple of years.
And then the night before
shooting started,
I just started getting these
e-mails from him.
And he was sending me the IMDB
resumes of actors he thought
should be better than him.
And he was like,
"Can I not go to work tomorrow
What about Emile Hirsch?
You know, what about
Cole Sprouse?"
And all these resumes
keep popping up.
And I'm at home laughing
thinking, oh, he's hysterical.
This Pete, he's hysterical
And then the next day at wor
he's like, "I'm serious.
You should have called
Cole Sprouse."
-[ Laughs ]
-"I really --
I really don't want to be here
today, Judd."
But then after the first day
he got really comfortable
and had a blast making it.
But he certainly was a littl
nervous heading into it.
-A directors fear, one of thei
many fears on set is something
will change with an actor an
there will be continuity issues.
-Yes.
-What was your biggest
continuity fear about Pete
-The biggest fear I had wa
he loves getting tattoos.
-Yeah.
-That's just like
the after like,
"Oh, look how good it looks.
I think it's the process
of getting it.
He talked a lot about enjoying
the fact that it hurt
and that it focused him
and helped him think clearly
And we talked a lot about trying
to understand that.
And so, he kept asking
if he could get a tattoo
in a weird place that
wouldn't be in the movie.
And I'm like, "I don't kno
when I need you naked.
I might need you naked one day
You can't have a new tattoo.
And then I was worried
he would go
like full Post Malone
at some point.
-Right, sure.
-Because that would happen -
When we were doing "Girls,
in between seasons,
they would get tattoos
and they wouldn't ask anybody.
They would just show up and go
"Do you love these tattoos
I got all over my hands?
And I'm like, "I guess you
character just got tattoos
on her hands."
-Man, yeah.